est-ce que certains d'entre vous
souhaitent ou travaillent dans la
finance
personnellement ça n'était absolument
pas mon objectif moi je suis Ch'tis né à
Grenoble et des investisseurs j'en avais
absolument jamais rencontré
et l'image que j'en avais se résumé à
Gordon gecko dans le film Wall Street ne
dort jamais ou en fait le seul objectif
c'est de s'en mettre plein les poches
et
en sortant d'école mon objectif c'était
de devenir entrepreneur
après deux projets dont un qui n'a pas
fonctionné
j'ai compris que si je voulais monter ma
start-up il fallait que je comprenne la
finance
et donc dans le cadre de mon stage de
fin d'étude j'ai décidé de rejoindre un
groupe anglais qui cartonnait dans la
vente de services digitaux en ligne
mon rôle il consistait à
identifier des startups à fort potentiel
pour que l'entreprise est réinvestisse
ses profits
les premiers mois c'était génial Paris
Londres Tel Aviv j'avais carte blanche
et jusqu'au jour où je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais tombé dans une
formidable arnaque
100 millions d'euros
au début j'ai extrêmement honte je
savais pas vers qui me tournait vers qui
en parlait
et
j'ai décidé de quitter l'entreprise
et pour moi c'est là que je me suis
rendu compte que l'alignement de mes
valeurs morales et des valeurs de
l'entreprise dans laquelle je
travaillais c'était
hyper important et cette alignement ça
deviendrait l'étoile polaire que je suis
vrai dans tous mes choix de carrière
future
et c'est là qui a démarré ma quête de
sens
dans mon travail j'avais besoin de sens
et il y avait une question qui me
tournait sans cesse dans la tête qui
était mais finalement j'ai deux diplômes
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour avoir
de l'impact quel type de métier par où
par quel bout commencer
et pour répondre à ces questions j'ai
décidé depuis 7 ans d'offrir 80% de mes
vacances en mettant au service
d'organisation sociale exceptionnelle
à partir de mes compétences qui sont la
mesure d'impact et la digitalisation et
ses aventures elles m'ont emmené au fin
fond de la jungle la frontière avec le
Congo en Ouganda dans un bidonville en
Inde dans le plus gros bidonville
d'Afrique de l'Est dans les favelas au
Brésil cet été ou encore dans les
quartiers nord de Marseille et à chaque
fois j'ai rencontré des organisations
exceptionnelles qui avaient du sens qui
avait des valeurs fortes et qui avait un
impact concret
dans le cas d'une de mes aventures je
suis parti en Inde
en Inde je me suis rendu dans une des
plus grandes décharges une décharge qui
s'appelait shillaginagar ou s'entasser
des milliers de musulmans rejetés par la
société à dominance en nous cette
aventure elle a été particulièrement
rude parce que pendant la période de
mousson des eaux noires nauséabondes et
pleines de maladies venez inonder les
habitations des habitants
pour me rendre à l'association Tous les
tous les matins j'avais cette fameuse
eau qui me remontait jusqu'au dessus des
chevilles l'espérance de vie elle était
39 ans
c'était l'une des rares associations à
être présente dans ces quartiers pour
venir en aide aux familles
le problème majeur qu'ils avaient
c'était la mortalité infantile qui était
l'une des plus élevées du monde
ils avaient deux options la première
option aurait pu être d'embaucher des
médecins mais ça aurait coûté cher et
surtout le jour où il y a plus de budget
le problème tombe à l'eau dans notre
côté apnalaya est collectait la data et
ils sont rendus compte qu'à partir du
moment
ils sont rendus compte que que 99% des
habitants n'avaient pas de carte
d'identité
si on n'a pas de carte d'identité pour
pour pouvoir avoir une carte d'identité
il faut il faut avoir un extrait de
naissance et 90% dont j'avais pas non
plus
et à partir du moment on a une carte
d'identité et bien on pouvait se rendre
dans les hôpitaux gratuitement et
bénéficier d'un suivi médical et
d'échographie et donc qu'a fait
l'association ils ont plutôt décidé de
loin locale d'acheter des ordinateurs de
mobiliser un staff qui viendrait former
ces familles à faire des marches
administratives puis ensuite à payer un
ticket de bus pour que les femmes
enceintes puissent se rendre à l'hôpital
au bout de quelques mois ils sont rendus
compte qu'au bout de la partie du moment
où 40% des habitants étaient formés dans
un quartier ils pouvaient s'autoformer
les uns avec les autres au bout de 10
ans la quasi-totalité des femmes se
rendaient à l'hôpital et le taux de
mortalité infantile avait drastiquement
chuté
le facteur limitant de chacune des
organisations dont un pnealia à qui j'ai
pu rendre visite
c'est l'accès aux financement c'est le
manque de moyens
l'accès aux financement ces réseaux de
personnes fortunées on pourrait se poser
la question comment ça fonctionne
comment ça se structure quels sont les
rouages derrière ces réseaux de
personnes fortunées
j'avais besoin de trouver des réponses
et c'est là que j'ai fait la rencontre
d'un homme qui s'appelle Alexandre mars
un entrepreneur philanthrope qui a monté
des startups qui a fait fortune dans les
revendants et qui a voulu utiliser
sa fortune pour avoir un maximum
d'impact et pour cela il voulait laver
pour projet de créer une fondation qui
serait financée par un fonds
d'investissement responsable
c'était l'occasion en or pour moi de me
replonger dans le monde des affaires
pour y trouver ces fameuses réponses et
surtout Alexandre m'a donné ma chance
mon premier métier au sein de ce fonds
d'investissement c'était de partir à la
rencontre de ces multimillionnaires de
ces milliardaires afin de leur proposer
d'investir avec nous dans des projets
autour des nouvelles technologies toutes
les semaines je partais dans un pays
différent moi qui viens pas du tout de
ce monde j'ai fait de sacré découverte
notamment j'ai cassé un certain nombre
de préjugés que j'avais sur les
personnes fortunées où j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de personnes bienveillantes
très discrètes et engagées
pas tout non plus
et je vous partageais une rencontre avec
Sam
un jeune homme de mon âge qui était qui
est héritier d'une des plus grandes
familles américaines d'une des plus
grandes fortunes américaines et sa
famille était investie dans trois
domaines
les activités pétrolières le plus grand
réseau de distribution de décence donc
des stations essence qui vendent les
cigarettes les moins chères et des
forêts
et ça m'a partagé ses réflexions sur
l'investissement responsable en
m'expliquant que l'État taxe sera
beaucoup plus ces activités pétrolières
de par toutes ces aberrations
écologiques notamment les marées noires
que l'État taxera beaucoup plus les
cigarettes de par l'impact que ça peut
avoir sur la santé et le coup que ça
peut avoir pour l'assurance maladie
lesquels les forêts les propriétaires de
forêt se verront rétribué pour leur
contribution à la captation du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère et c'est sur ces arguments
que Sam cherchait à convaincre sa
famille de se désengager de certains
secteurs au profit de d'autres plus
responsables et plus durable
Sam engagé et financier
le premier deal sur lequel j'ai
travaillé c'est Spotify
on est investi à plusieurs reprises
jusqu'à devenir l'un des plus gros
actionnaires avec une position estimée à
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars
le 3 avril 2018 le jour de mon
anniversaire
Spotify est entré en bourse à Wall
Street
et en l'espace de quelques minutes les
traders nous ont acheté des centaines de
millions de dollars j'étais complètement
abasourdi le monde de la finance et du
capitalisme était capable de mobiliser
des milliards de dollars comme ça en une
fraction de seconde
et c'est là que je me suis posé la
question est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
utiliser cette finance et ce monde
capitaliste pour dessiner les contours
d'une société plus juste et plus
responsable
et c'est l'une des
c'est l'un des c'est vraiment ce qui
m'anime aujourd'hui dans ma quête de
sens et c'est clairement la raison pour
laquelle je fais de la finance
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on pourrait
faire converger deux monde que l'on a
toujours distingué les ONG et les
entreprises les ONG qui ont du sens
et les entreprises qui ont les moyens
dans le cadre de mon travail et de mes
aventures je me suis rendu compte que
les ONG elles tendent à se
professionnaliser
tandis que les entreprises elles
cherchent à donner plus de sens elle
cherche à devenir plus responsable
j'ai fait la rencontre d'un entrepreneur
qui s'appelle Cameron
Cameron c'est le fondateur d'une startup
qui s'appelle Prodigy finance
Prodigy finance ISO 3D prêts à des
dizaines de milliers d'étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent financer des leurs
études dans des dans des universités
prestigieuses
la mission d'intérêt général de produits
Jeff finance c'est de réduire les
inégalités sociales autour de
l'éducation par exemple un étudiant qui
vient du Zimbabwe qui admis à Harvard
Business School ou hackage qui a besoin
d'un prêt s'il va avoir la banque
américaine il va être très probablement
considéré comme un étudiant à risque
il n'obtiendra pas le prêt dans son pays
il obtiendra très probablement un taux
prohibitif
Cameron il aurait pu monter une ONG un
projet philanthropique pour pouvoir
venir en aide à quelques étudiants
chaque année
il a pris une autre décision il a pris
il a fait le choix d'utiliser ses
compétences en finance pour développer
un produit permettant de définir le
risque sur un étudiant pour lui proposer
un prêt au juste prix
et ce qui est génial c'est que ça a
marché il a réussi à mobiliser plus d'un
milliard de dollars auprès de crédit
Suisse de Dodge Bank de Goldman Sachs
voilà une image de ce que la finance
peut faire au service d'une conscience
Cameron
financier
et engagé
dans le cadre de mon travail
notre raison d'être dans le fond
d'investissement dans laquelle je
travaille c'est d'être les plus
supportifs possibles pour des
entrepreneurs engagés
certifié bicorps si certains connaissent
toute l'équipe s'est engagée à reverser
20% de nos profits à des organisations
sociales
mon premier travail qui consistait à
lever de l'argent ensuite évoluer pour
être en charge de l'investir
je suis maintenant directeur des
investissements dans un dans ce fond en
charge de la zone Europe on a investi
dans des entreprises comme Spotify comme
Pinterest comme too good to go Comet
space ou encore le média brut
toutes les semaines je rencontre des
entrepreneurs qui me présente leurs
projets et moi ce qui me passionne ce
sont les projets qui arrivent à lier un
modèle économique viable
avec une mission d'intérêt général
et j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait trois
types d'entrepreneurs
on va retrouver des entrepreneurs qui
seront activistes et là il y a pas
besoin de les convaincre ils sont déjà
convaincus
il y a les entrepreneurs que
j'appellerai les dinosaures et cela on
cherchera pas à les accompagner et enfin
il y a les pragmatiques pour moi c'est
la plus grande partie des entrepreneurs
et tout l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à
convaincre qu'un engagement responsable
c'est avant tout une décision business
par exemple on a investi dans une
entreprise dans laquelle les dirigeants
s'étaient engagés sur trois grands
projets responsables dont un qui
consistait à mesurer leur empreinte
carbone une fois qu'on avait investi on
s'est rendu compte que une bonne partie
des dirigeants était finalement pas si
convaincu que ça et repousser le projet
au calendrier grec
une de mes collègues talentueuse leur a
proposé de les prendre par la main pour
sélectionner la bonne plateforme mettre
en place les bons process pour qu'ils
puissent mesurer leur impact jusqu'à les
convaincre de DOF CT l'intégralité de
leur empreinte ce qui représentait
plusieurs millions de dollars
et ce qui est vraiment génial dans cette
démarche c'est que ça a été ils sont
rendus compte que c'était une décision
business parce que pour signer leur
principaux projets partenariat
stratégiques notamment avec certaines
des plus grandes célébrités dans le
sport ces célébrités leur demandaient
très bien le partenariat mais c'est quoi
vos engagements c'est quoi votre plan
environnemental et c'est là qu'ils sont
bien content de pouvoir montrer un
certain nombre d'engagements
c'était une décision liée au business
engagement et business
ce qui me fascine aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on voit l'émergence d'entreprise qui
sont activistes activistes dans la
mission même de l'entreprise
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
connaissent l'application smartphone too
good to go mais aujourd'hui un tiers de
l'alimentation et gaspillée dans le
monde ce qui représente à peu près 10%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
la cofondatrice Lucie bache dans le
cadre d'un stage chez Nestlé c'était
rendu compte que l'un des endroits où
l'on avait le plus de gaspillage c'est
dans la grande distribution et dans la
consommation donc dans les dans les
restaurants dans les supermarchés
dans les dans les hôtels etc dans les
boulangeries
et donc tout Go c'est une plateforme qui
permet de valoriser les denrées
alimentaires qui arrivent à date
d'expiration et pour ça ils mettent en
lien des magasins avec des clients en
tant qu'utilisateur je me suis rendu
compte que finalement tout le monde y
trouvait son compte les magasins ça leur
permet de valoriser leurs denrées qui
arrivent à daxpiration ça leur fait des
revenus complémentaires et ça leur
permet d'attirer des nouveaux clients
dans leur magasin pour les clients ils
font une bonne affaire tout en faisant
geste pour l'environnement et pour tout
good to go en mettant une commission sur
chaque repas sauvé
ils ont pu allier un modèle économique
viable avec une mission environnementale
aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui too
good to go ils sont présents dans 17
pays avec une croissance exponentielle
ce qui m'a vraiment marqué au moment de
l'investissement en to good to go c'est
que la dirigeante quand on l'a rencontré
nous a dit avant que je vous partage le
moindre chiffre sur l'entreprise
prouvez-moi vous fonds d'investissement
que vos valeurs et votre mission elle
est alignée avec les valeurs et la
mission de Tood to go trouvez-moi que
les gens qui vous ont confié de l'argent
aucun d'entre eux n'a fait d'évasion
fiscale
aucun d'entre eux n'a fait fortune dans
des secteurs qui sont discutables et
prouver le moi
la fondatrice de too good to go la
dirigeante de too good to go
finance et engagement
le message que j'aimerais vous partager
aujourd'hui
c'est que il existe différentes formes
d'activisme effectivement il est
important qu'il y ait des jeunes qui se
qui se mobilisent dans des organisations
de plaidoyer qui vont ouvrir des débats
ouvrez des discussions voir même parfois
descendre dans la rue pour manifester
mais il existe une autre forme
d'activisme
nous avons besoin de jeunes qui partent
travailler dans les grands groupes dans
les startups dans la finance qui vont
chercher à en comprendre les codes et
les rouages pour changer les choses de
l'intérieur
en tant qu'investisseur on a un rôle à
jouer pour financer les entreprises
activités
et donc aujourd'hui j'ai une question à
vous poser qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire pour donner du sens pensez-vous
pas qu'on peut remettre en cause la
norme
moi en tant qu'investisseur moi je suis
convaincu d'une chose c'est qu'on peut
tous agir à notre échelle
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]